wireless controllers we love them
because they're convenient sometimes we
hate them because they run out of
batteries thanks to my Co Xbox one
owners have a way to curb this issue
with its modular power station this
add-on connects to the side of the Xbox
one and comedian Lee charges two
batteries so you always have a back-up
plan we just got this from my cows let's
take a look and see how it works the
mega power station snaps onto the side
of your Xbox one drawing power from the
USB port charged to 1000 milliamp hour
batteries which Nyko promises will last
for twenty-five hours of peace the power
station bears a striking resemblance to
the Xbox one's design and materials
which is good because while it extends
the width of the console by about two
inches it doesn't stand out in a
negative way like so many aftermarket
products tend to though it attaches next
to event on the Xbox one with events of
its own the power station doesn't
actually impede hot air from escaping
your console while it does take over the
USB port on the side you still have
access to a pair of ports on the back of
the Xbox one the power station unit
opens up with the press of a button on
the front battery packs are easy to
insert and remove with very little
effort and while they're charging you
can keep track of how far along they are
by taking a quick look at the simple
indicators in the front for $30 Legos
modular power station is a pretty good
deal and a great way to make sure you
never run out of batteries for your Xbox
one controllers now does it make the
arty large Xbox one bigger yes but
that's a small price to pay to make sure
you never have ton for batteries or
delay gameplay for more games tech
content stay tuned to game spot calm
you